so excited to introduce our next
wildflower
in honor of veterans day after serving
12
years in the military yvonne neal
started an
art program to help other female
veterans
so and here she is hi evani how are you
so excited to be here drew hey
when i was reading your dossier which
makes me feel like
oprah slash some secret service person
that's how i get a lot of my research
and when i received your dossier
i was just really moved by
the fact that art speaks to you
and that you want to take that to
other people so after your discharge in
2011
it became an outlet for you art and you
wanted to give that
outlet to others um why did you feel
that that was important
well art for me basically cleared my
mind
it calmed me down it gave me a place to
express
myself and non-verbal
um it was an outlet for me
um sometimes veterans don't have that
outlet
and i wanted to provide a opportunity
for veterans to express themselves
through
art and give back to my local community
and may i ask where did your love of art
start did you see a painting when you
were younger or did you just pick up a
brush
what sparked oh my god
my grandmother was so creative and she
sparked that in me
and um the first thing she taught me was
the hand quote
oh that is so beautiful
and now that you want to teach others
and you have been
but we are in 2020 and
so the step you would like to be able to
take is moving your students to virtual
are you able to do that well right now
because i don't have all of the
technical equipment
it's hard i would love
to do this virtually um that's one of my
goals
i'm excited about it um i see so much
for the future especially with what
we're going through right now
uh people need that outlet yeah i like
to know how i get out with
them and you share a laptop with your
son
right yes we do so you need your own
yes yes yes yes well
we have a computer for you you can have
all to yourself
a beautiful macbook we are so excited
oh my goodness thank you oh i can't
thank you
thank you well that's not all we wanted
to make sure that you had all the art
supplies you need and so
joanne stores wanted to help and they
are going to gift you five thousand
dollars worth of art supplies
you stop the madness oh my goodness
with these two steps yvonne we want to
help
enable all your important goals that
means so much
not only to you and us watching but
everybody that you'll affect
along the way so we're going to send
this right over to you so you can get
started and then your son can be on his
and you can be on yours
and you can get going thank you
thank you yvonne for everything that you
do
thank you
thank you drew oh my god happy veterans
day veterans
happy veterans day thank you
[Music]